with Professor Hiroshi Ishii,
and we built this array of
512 different electromagnets,
and together they were able to move objects around
on top of their surface.
But the problem with this
was that these magnets
cost over 10,000 dollars.
Although each one was pretty small,
altogether they weighed so much
that the table that they were on
started to sag.
So I wanted to build something
where you could have this kind of interaction
on any tabletop surface.
So to explore this idea,
I built an army of small robots,
and each of these robots has what are called omni wheels.
They're these special wheels
that can move equally easily in all directions,
and when you couple these robots
with a video projector,
you have these physical tools
for interacting with digital information.
So here's an example of what I mean.
This is a video editing application
where all of the controls
for manipulating the video are physical.
So if we want to tweak the color,
we just enter the color mode,
and then we get three different dials
for tweaking the color,
or if we want to adjust the audio,
then we get two different dials for that, these physical objects.
So here the left and right channel stay in sync,
but if we want to, we can override that
by grabbing both of them at the same time.
So the idea is that we get the speed
and efficiency benefits of using these physical dials
together with the flexibility and versatility
of a system that's designed in software.
And this is a mapping application
for disaster response.
So you have these physical objects
that represent police, fire and rescue,
and a dispatcher can grab them
and place them on the map
to tell those units where to go,
and then the position of the units on the map
gets synced up with the position
of those units in the real world.
This is a video chat application.
It's amazing how much emotion you can convey
with just a few simple movements
of a physical object.
With this interface, we open up a huge array of possibilities
in between traditional board games
and arcade games,
where the physical possibilities of interaction
make so many different styles of play possible.
But one of the areas that I'm most excited
about using this platform for
is applying it to problems that are difficult
for computers or people to solve alone.
One example of those is protein folding.
So here we have an interface
where we have physical handles onto a protein,
and we can grab those handles
and try to move the protein and try to fold it in different ways.
And if we move it in a way that doesn't really make sense
with the underlying molecular simulation,
we get this physical feedback where we can
actually feel these physical handles
pulling back against us.
So feeling what's going on
inside a molecular simulation
is a whole different level of interaction.
So we're just beginning to explore
what's possible when we use software
to control the movement
of objects in our environment.
Maybe this is the computer of the future.
There's no touchscreen.
There's no technology visible at all.
But when we want to have a video chat
or play a game
or lay out the slides to our next TED Talk,
the objects on the table come alive.
Thank you.
(Applause)